robert spencer with russia suffering
huge losses in men and materials in
ukraine
thousands of lives lost in thousands and
thousands of pieces of equipment very
expensive stuff destroyed by the
ukrainians will there be a peace now
that will guarantee the sovereignty of
ukraine
it could happen but really i don't know
who to believe because there has been so
much that has been then later retracted
coming out of ukraine coming out of
russia coming out of our own dishonest
media
i don't know what's going on there
really but it does look as if
obviously the russians haven't conquered
kiev
zielinski is still there and so maybe
this isn't really isn't going the way
they had planned
and maybe they will settle for the
russian areas of ukraine and leave the
ukrainians alone we'll see certainly can
hope